Oh
well we're thinking about things we're
already seeing warm air holds more water
vapor than cold the atmosphere is about
5% more moisture in it than it had 40
years ago which is an astonishingly
large change in a basic physical
parameter that means that we're seeing
huge increases in the amount of delusion
downpour and flood there's a record
rainfall and flooding someplace around
the world almost every week now the
hundred year storm comes to many places
every three or four years it's taking a
great toll on infrastructure on human
life you know this spring we watched a
hundreds of people killed in rio in the
middle of rio de janeiro in mud slides
after the largest rain storms they'd
ever recorded in that city um I look at
the chemistry of seawater I mean the
ocean is the our metaphor for vastness
on this planet but that hasn't stopped
it from changing in profound ways
seawater is thirty percent more acidic
than it was 40 or 50 years ago because
the oceans are absorbing so much carbon
from the atmosphere everything frozen on
earth is melting glaciers are melting
with great rapidity all over the planet
some of them have disappeared in the
western US in the Andes you can go on
for many days just listing the effects
we've already seen if we don't do things
quickly the effects that are coming as
the temperature gets hotter and hotter
will be even more dramatic the latest
studies indicate that by the mid to
latter part of the century we could be
seeing grain yields for corn and soybean
and wheat fall 20 30 40 percent um that
would be trouble of a all encompassing
sort
new planet we need new habits new ways
of going about things the biggest habit
on our planet at the moment is a kind of
addiction to economic growth and to the
idea that growth will solve every
problem that we face that's a habit
we're going to have to habit of mind
really that we're going to have to get
out of we've reached those limits to
growth that people started talking about
in the 1970s when you melt the Arctic
that's a pretty good sign that you've
gone too far and so we're going to need
to figure out instead how to build a
world that is stable secure kind of
hunkered down it's built for built for
endurance not for speed pecan and I
think that means more and more that our
economies will need to become more
localized less sprawling less vulnerable
more resilient we can see that starting
slowly to happen the number of farms in
the united states increased last five
years for the first time in a century
and a half it's because there's this
local food movement that's building up
at kind of resilience in place after
place